♫ Gonna roll it into a log, rollin a pizza
♫ It's from Armenia ♫
(light guitar strumming)
- It's kind of like, near
the middle east, right?
- I drive by Little Armenia all the time,
and it smells amazing.
- I love any food that
can be the adult version
of Lunchables.
- Sort of like a meaty fruit leather.
It looks like my tongue.
- This is something
that I would wanna have
with like a beer.
- Very subtle spice.
- Oh, the lettuce makes it.
- Yeah, you have to have
it with the lettuce.
- It kinda reminds me
of ketchup fried rice,
that my mom made as a kid.
- To each his own.
- Why can't more things be
delivered on little leaf spoons?
(laughs)
- That tastes like it
came right off the nipple.
- It tastes like salty,
watered down yogurt.
- I could dip a cucumber in
this, and just go all day.
- One would expect something
that looks like this
to either be sweet, or taste
like milk, and it's neither.
- This looks like a
zestier matzoh ball soup.
- I like how gentle the broth
is, it's just a whisper.
- It feels like I'm alone in a
bathtub, reading a good book.
Does it not?
- Do you eat soup in the tub?
- What kinda meat is it?
- [Guy] Lamb
- [Girl] No.
- I like that a lot of this
food has been like low carb.
- This is like, the
ultimate feel good food,
I feel like every culture has something
that they want when they
come home on a fall day.
- Dude, I know pizza, and this is pizza.
- Feel like if I came home from school,
and my mom had made me this,
I would just be like yes.
- (bleep) yeah, mom.
Lahmajun, baby.
- It's more peppery.
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah, the pepper, the
meat, the lemon, the onion.
- This demands to be rolled up.
- My pinkies need to
be up for this taquito.
- This is kind of like, the
sweetness that I'm used to,
because in Japanese cultures, it's like,
very also subdued sweetness.
- Ah, this looks good.
Oh, it's warm.
- This looks like Donald Trump's hair.
Or quite possibly the most
delicious thing I've ever tasted.
- Feel like I'm eatin' a sweet hairball.
(gargles)
(speaks Armenian)
- It tastes like what it smells like
to walk into a Christmas store.
- All my organs are tingling.
- Went straight to my armpits.
- This like, opened up
my nasal passageways.
- Man, Armenian people
like to party, am I right?
- I've lived throughout the
middle east, and I love,
um, Arab culture,
there's a lot of overlap,
so I've really enjoyed it.
- It's all something that you
would gather over a big table,
and just share and have a good time with.
- There's no weird stuff,
it's meatballs in soup.
- This coulda been baklava,
but then you cook it in a
completely different way,
and you have something that
tastes just as amazing,
and a completely different
like, flavor palette.
(funky guitar)